for a moment there it almost looked as
if we could glimpse the light at the end
of the economic tunnel
at the start of this year the economy
was bouncing back after covid people
were spending again now things are
looking more worrying
with inflation now expected to be in
double digits for months the bank of
england have raised interest rates to
the highest level since 2008.
for those who run businesses even those
doing pretty well the challenges seem to
be coming from all angles from the
falling pound which makes imports more
expensive to the cost of well everything
else inflation is a sort of a triple
edge sword if you like because you've
got the impact on supply chain and uh
you know the way that we bring goods
into the business and trying to protect
our customers from that
but absolutely the impact on demand
because customers feel as though things
are more important even if we're trying
to protect them our average price has
only gone up by about five percent but
they'll be seeing prices rise everywhere
and therefore the propensity to buy is
probably it's more difficult to get them
to to come to to make a big ticket item
the bank actually thinks the uk is
technically in recession now although
that's largely down to the impact of two
extra bank holidays this year the real
question is what happens next we're
already seeing signs that the economy is
slowing from short-term indicators and
that kind of thing we're going to see
more of that in the coming months
partly because of the interest rate rise
and higher bills but also because of the
rise in the cost of living
now in historical context 2.25 percent
isn't very high and even 4.75 percent
which is where they're expected to go
next year doesn't look like much
especially compared to those
double-digit levels in the 80s and the
90s but don't be fooled because these
days households are much more indebted
their incomes much lower compared with
their mortgage repayments once you
adjust for mortgage affordability the
red line here those double-digit rates
of the 1980s were actually equivalent to
about three percent in today's housing
market suddenly 4.75 percent rates
looked quite scary the last two times
the red line hit those levels we had a
housing crash not long afterwards
perhaps that explains why the bank
didn't lift borrowing costs quite as
much as some expected now it might sound
strange to hear a 0.5 percentage point
increase the joint biggest that we've
had since the 1990s described as small
but actually there were a lot of people
including three members of the monetary
policy committee who would rather it was
even bigger 0.75
percentage points why because on the
other side of town in westminster the
government is writing blank checks
financed by borrowing that means more
money sloshing around and all else equal
you would expect an institution like the
bank to act and act fast
for those with mortgages that will mean
higher costs for savers it's better news
but on top of everything else inflation
energy bills it all seems to point to a
weaker economy
and the inescapable logic of higher
inflation is that everyone gets squeezed
at the same time businesses like brook
salon here in telford and her clients
too i'm in a position where i need to
raise my prices because i've hit that
but also
now the electricity prices have gone up
and as well as my stock prices already
um going up 12 like what am i what am i
meant to do as a as a business owner am
i meant to just um inflict that all onto
my my clients well i'm they're not going
to pay that i can tell you that now
they're not going to pay 57 on top of
what they're already paying economists
love saying there's no such thing as a
free lunch but they've got a point and
it applies here
even if the government succeeds in
boosting economic growth there is a
sting in the tail higher interest rates
potentially much higher
ed conway sky news